grand master sam shanklin what's going
on in that engine of course first of all
congratulations i think sam would rather
just talk about his game
and the win he had today that's a big
win against a world class player sam
congratulations this game was sharp in
the beginning it looked like he got the
better of you in the opening but then
you were able to turn things around at
some point and win the game yeah these
last couple days have been weird you end
up better with black out of the opening
and losing and then worse with white and
winning i mean that's sort of not
what's supposed to happen at this level
but that's happened the last two days
for me um
but yeah i don't know i just i think i
got out prepared or somehow tricked and
i thought queen d8 was supposed to be
inaccurate when he played it and if i
recall it was because of bishop g5
either here or queen e2 first and then
bishop g5 but i just couldn't remember
the details the next thing i knew
i realized that after um
after bishop g3 e4 that i was thinking
of going knight e5 uh and i thought i
had nice position and next on rosette
knight takes e5 bishop f2 and that's
that
um it's possible he can even start with
knight g4 i think this is just sort of
collapsing already and i just missed
that um and next thing i can just resign
already i think so
uh
then i'm already thinking okay like am i
just worse i mean after queen e2 i was
even thinking he could castle like i
thought i was worse there as well like
after i was calculating d e4 knight e4
uh queen e4 rook e8 and then knight e5
and i think it was a very important move
queen f6 and i think i'm just worse um
maybe not that much worse after like
castle's 95 knight d2 but
it's definitely unpleasant and i was
just really annoyed with myself i'm like
just bad position with white but then he
really surprised me when he took back on
e7 with the bishop i thought he
absolutely should take with
with the king because
uh when i was able to play f takes g3
and get myself castled short all of a
sudden my position makes some degree of
sense but if he takes with the king this
plan will not work because i cannot
castle short and so
i'm just not going to get the kind of
activity that i got and i'm going to
suffer against the two bishops i'm just
slightly worse and
uh will remain slightly worse for a long
time and that's not a great feeling
after queen e7 i already felt pretty
happy i mean i'm i'm sure he has to be
fine somehow but or better probably but
i just i was reasonably satisfied with
my position around here and yeah just
kept playing uh he did have an idea that
was really weird and i'm sure you didn't
look at it because we were disgusted
when the engine showed it was here he
could have played the move bishop to c5
after bishop c6 i did consider this so
actually i thought that was a it was a
serious detail uh or yeah okay he
castled first but same thing though
castles and allow you because if he's
gonna do it he has to do it right away
or else knight b3 will come but here
after knight b3 and then knight e5 i
thought i should be equalizing but maybe
that was too optimistic well the point
was if you try to move c4 instead no
that this i thought would be no no sorry
95 was correct 95 was the correct move
yeah and i thought i just i thought i
should be equalizing here i mean his
rooks are active but it
didn't seem that bad somehow
the bishop uh the bishop was stronger
than your night here perhaps but it's a
simplified position i guess the big
problem is my king is stuck forever
right i think that's the real issue that
i hadn't appreciated i don't know i mean
at some point i was just thinking would
have half the bishop pair i've messed up
his structure like i've actually gotten
something from what should have just
been a miserable position earlier on the
point was that the move c4 uh
c4 allows the move c5 by black yeah and
this kind of thing it's i think it's
just bad for me uh the the bad knight on
b3 versus the bad bishop on b6 i think
the knight is worse
uh and the bishop can become better and
the yeah a5 a4 g4 it's all coming and
this i just i saw a lot of positions
like this because i actually played for
c4 later on and i understood that if he
gets c5 i'm just going to be worse and i
had to be calculating very carefully
like when that happened
well very good that shows why you're a
2700 player to understand that you can
have this bad bishop and be
better well i don't know around here i
just sort of started not understanding
his moves i mean rook d5 i didn't get it
uh you're not stopping me from doing
what i want so yeah and here he has to
give
the bishop and i still think black's
basically fine but i was expecting c5
not king b7 well after king b7 i was
still struggling to find the way
um
but yeah here basically i thought if he
can stop me from getting my knight to c5
like if i go c4 and ic5 i'm probably
just going to win this game uh if i can
keep all the rooks on the board or if i
can go c4 knight a5 and b4 but i think
he could have stopped it so after king
b6 c4 i was very surprised by rook d7 i
thought he absolutely needed rook d3
here so that i cannot play a4
and um
yeah here i wanted to play rookie seven
uh when it's a little bit annoying to
stop c5 and that a5 check and
but he can play like rook c8 or
something which is ugly but i also
didn't see a great way to make further
progress here i mean somehow i
i thought i should just play it and let
him find his way here but once he played
rook d7 and i went a4 i thought it was
already very bad for black because if i
go a5 and knight c5 this game is totally
finished and once i realize that the
tactics work out that if c5 i have a5
and rookie 5
and if um
if a5 has you played i had this idea to
go rook f6 and then um and then rookie 5
was i thought it was basically just
winning i couldn't see a way for him
here after rookie 5.
this was a very nice uh touch this rook
b5 chat yeah i almost blundered it here
actually though i was about to play rook
c5 uh threatening to take on c6 i'm
pointing out that if he plays bishop e4
i have misplaced his bishop
and i can now go rook b5 check again and
now i go knight c5 and then he's gone if
i'm not mistaken this i thought was over
because if his bishop is hanging while
on the other line it wouldn't be but
then i realized that after rook c5 he
could have conrook d6 and i no longer
have c5 check
that i think i can basically i mean i
don't know what i thought i was almost
busted here actually
my rook on c5 is goofy too i guess i can
go rook cf5
i mean this was i almost blundered this
away but oh that would have been very
painful saying yeah but this is yeah
here and i think this should be winning
i didn't see a defense as this went so i
mean i was a little surprised when he
resigned on my move at the end i thought
but i thought i could still somehow
screw this up but
yeah i mean here i was just
calculating the difference between rook
b6 and rook rook b6 rook g6 and rook g6
directly i believe they both win but uh
i was like there was one line if rook g6
he can play bishop e2 and um
rook g3 and rook d8 and i'm going to
lose the c pawn but it doesn't matter
that king gets to b6 and that should be
that um
and he could have played rook c8 instead
of rook d8 to try to keep me awkward but
i can play like rook c3 and it's clumsy
but i i will reorganize and win
uh or if i had played rook b6 check and
it's yeah so here just i think rook c3
should be fine probably rook g7 wins too
but
um
but yeah here i was thinking also i can
start with rook v6 check king c8 to not
give him the c8 square rook g6 but this
one is a little annoying rook g6 now to
get behind his g pawn yep and then but
this one now that his king is no longer
on a8 he's not actually checkmated so he
can play rook h3
uh and then a7 bishop f3 but i believe
i'm getting there getting back just in
time so bishop of three check on a8
uh king d7 i guess doesn't matter make a
queen
um
and then after bishop a8 and rook a8 if
g2 i have rook g8 and if rook g4 rook if
rook to h4 g4 i'm going to be just in
time with rook one rook g1 so
uh
i was just making sure i believe both
moves win but yeah jacques resigned i
guess instead of waiting for it
wow big time win against a big time
player
your feelings about the tournament now
yeah i mean obviously it's still not
great i'm on minus one which is not
where i want to be at all i mean uh but
uh it certainly looks a lot better than
it did yesterday i was pretty mad at
myself after this game with mexium where
i just like prepared to the point where
black is better against like one of the
best players in the world and then
i at the end i completely lost my sense
of danger i thought we're just making a
draw on one more move next thing i know
the pawn ending is lost by one tempo in
every single variation like every single
one 20 moves deep it's always one tempo
lost and uh so i was very upset with
myself for that um
but yeah now this feels better i mean i
i think i got a bit of a gift today
there's no way i should beat a player of
mohammed yar's caliber from this kind of
like just unpleasant game but you know i
did my best and played well
all right well good luck tomorrow and
the rest of the tournament